a very warm welcome to all viewers
it is crazer from simply learn and in
this video
we will be looking at the installation
of uipath
as you might already know uipath is an
rps software tool
used for business and it to know more
about the uipath tool
you can check out our uipath tutorial
in this video we will look at the
requirements before installing the ui
part 2
then we will look at the different
editions that uipath offers
for different users and finally we will
install the uipath software
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos
then subscribe to our youtube channel
and make sure you
press the bell icon to never miss an
update
so let us see the requirements
we will first look at the hardware
requirements
the cpu should at least have a processor
of 1.4 gigahertz
32-bit configuration or it's recommended
to have a 1.8 gigahertz
64-bit configuration the device
is recommended to have a ram of 8 gb
if not at least a minimum of 4 gb
let us look at the software requirements
if you are using a windows operating
system
then windows should be of version 8.1 or
8.1
n or 10 or 10 n and the windows server
should be of 2012 r2 2016
or 2019 versions another prerequisite
is to have dotnet framework of minimum
of 4.5.2 version installed
let us look at the additions the
different editions
that uipath offers uipath offers two
types of editions
community edition and enterprise edition
community edition
is for the developers and small teams
who are just starting on their
automation journey
the enterprise edition is further
classified into three types
enterprise studio edition enterprise
cloud edition
and enterprise server edition so
enterprise studio edition
is for individual enterprise developers
who want to experiment with ui path
studio
price cloud is a cloud-based deployment
of entire rpa enterprise platform for
any size business
enterprise server on-premises deployment
for
entire enterprise automation platform
for large scale business
let us look at the different profiles in
uipath ui path studio x
ui path studio and ui patch studio pro
ui path studio x is for business users
if you're not a developer but if you
want to automate a simple
task then it is easy to use a studio x
ui path studio it is for rpl developers
build complex automation that is run by
attended or unattended robots
uipath studio pro it is for specialized
developers
automate with the ai advanced rpa
features
testing tools and sophisticated coding
services
so we will look at the installation let
us install uipath
go to any one of the browser and search
for uipath.com
this will take you to the official ui
path website
here you can see try uipath for free
click here
since i have already registered before
it is showing as continued to existing
organization
if you are visiting this website for the
first time then
you might have to register or sign in
using an email account
after signing in and filling all the
details you can continue
here you can see download ui path studio
click on this and download the ui path
studio
here you go the ui path studio setup
file is getting downloaded
once the ui path file is downloaded run
the setup file
and here you can see the ui path is
getting installed after
installation it will ask for a license
select community license which is free
after selecting the license you need to
choose a profile
there are three profiles ui patch studio
pro
which is the advanced studio ide it has
features like testing tools
advanced rpa features and coding
services
another profile is ui path studio it is
for developers
who have pure programming experience
and the last profile is the ui path
studio x
it is for the people who don't have any
programming experience
so we will select uipath studio x for
now next ui path will ask you to update
the channel
you can either select the stable version
or preview version we will select the
stable version for now
after you select the versions you need
to select the source control plugins
you can enable git version control
system or apache sub version
and azure develop server uipath provides
a
short introduction video tutorials to
learn how to build
automations following step-by-step
instructions
and an academy to take free training on
the uipath academy
so that's it you have successfully
installed uipath studio
from here you can open a new project new
template
and start building the first automation
if you have any doubts regarding the ui
path installation
put it in the comment section below we
will reply to it
i hope you liked the video please like
share and subscribe
to our youtube channel
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here